level that you never gonna get back
truth always push it over to the brain
free never respect your respect
Retreat 50 to each time Ted
[Music]
the autopsy of Jane Doe is a brilliant
horror movie though he definitely
shouldn't overlook in all honesty it's
one of the best horror films that I've
seen in recent memory due to its
atmosphere and the fact it doesn't rely
on jump scares like the terrible
sinister Annabelle is sidious movies
that I just bought the crap out of me
with it cheap scares like Jane Doe
herself there's a lot of things beneath
the surface of this film that I'm really
gonna delve into in this video blog I'm
gonna cover my fan theory of what I
think the film is about and also just
discuss certain things that happen in
the movie the film focuses around Jane
Doe who gets brought into a mortuary to
be examined upon opening up the corpse
we discover things are not quite as they
seem and strange things begin to happen
the two coroner's soon discover that
whilst on the outside Jane Doe looks
fine on the inside she has been tortured
mutilated and destroyed in several
sadistic ways to me this is a metaphor
for the more that the two scientists
find themselves trapped in on the
outside things look fine once you down
beneath the surface everything's kind of
messed up and this theory is cemented
later on in the film when we see
characters remark that the weather's
been absolutely the best it's ever been
outside yeah from our perspective inside
the more we could see that it was
terrible outside apparently so there's a
clear difference between perception and
reality depending on what environment
you're in
it's totally contradictory so on the
outside of the morgue everything seemed
okay but beneath it seemed all messed up
which is a repetition of Jane Doe
herself almost every element in the film
has the appearance of being pristine and
in order while it's hiding a darker tone
beneath the surface and this ties
heavily in with the fact that the
coroner's wife committed suicide I've
also believed that Jane Doe herself is a
manifestation of Brian Cox
and the guilty feels over her suicide he
states that from the outside she seemed
happy and bubbly and full of life but
inside she dealt with depression anxiety
and a general feeling of unhappiness
this led to a suicide and once again
follows the motif that from the outside
things that alright but on the inside
the messed up depression is something
that rarely manifests on the surface
it's an inner struggle that people who
suffer from it deal with the fact that
Brian Cox's character was ignorant to
the turmoil that was going on within his
wife's - comeback in an almost become a
response to the former Jane Doe
she sadistically destroys the character
within their own minds
leaving them almost bun home on the
outside for the majority of the film and
torturing this really summarizes to me
that Jane Doe is a physical
manifestation of his wife he's come back
to torture the husband and son who
ignored her in a moment of need making
them go through the same things that she
went through much in the same way that
Jane Doe brought the terror inflicted on
her to her victims so what did you think
in the film I'd love to hear your
theories what you thought of mine if I'm
right if I'm wrong I don't care if you
think I'm wrong this safe thanks very
much for taking the time to check out my
video if you liked this please like it
and if you like to see more please
subscribe cuz I've been videos like this
all the time also check out my website
definition : UK where our review films
and also offer fan theories on certain
things that I think of it
thanks very much take care
[Music]